[موسيقى]
التطورات دراميه مهمه في الساحه بعد اعلان
الجيش اللي كانت مش الخليفه حصل تدمير
طائره تركيه في دول يعني في مطار طرابلس
اعتقال سته مواطنين اتراك قبل الافراج عن
مره اخرى وتهديد تركيا الاستهداف كل
مصالحها على الاراضي هي وتهديدات مماثله
من الجانب التركي لقواته
الحقيقه الى هذه التطورات بتطرح علينا
سؤال مهم ماذا يفعل اردوغان في لان احنا
عندنا في ليبيا في 12 دوله اجنبيه اه
موجوده على الاراضي الليبيه كل منها بحاول
اما المصالح المختلفه
وبينها دعمه احد اطراف الصراع ضد الاطراف
الاخرى الطرفين الاساسيين للصراع اه حكومه
الوفاق في الغرب ان المكونات الاساسيه لها
من التيارات الاسلاميه المختلفه
والجيش الليبي او القوات المشير الايفاء
وكل 12 دوله دول اذا كانت قوه عظمى زي
الولايات المتحده وروسيا ودولا وفرنسا
وايطاليا وبريطانيا والدول الاقليميه زي
مصر وتركيا
وقطر الى اخر والامارات كلهم منهم بيدعم
احد اطراف احد الاطراف الاساسيين في
الصراع
حكومه الوفاق في هذا الاطار الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان او تركيا موجوده واحده من ال
12 دوله دول علشان تدافع عن مصالحها لكن
هي تختلف عن ال 12 دوله دون في نقطه مهمه
جدا اللي 12 دوله ومنهم تركيا بيدافعوا عن
مصالحهم اذا كانت مصالح اقتصاديه مباشره
مخاطر زي الهجره مثلا على الاتحاد
الاوروبي او الفوضى على الحدود ما بين
الجزائر و ليبيا و الجزائر و مصر بالاضافه
طبعا الى اقول المشروعات الاقصى في هذا
البلد الموفور الثروات مشروعات في تامين م
مشروعات في مشروعات الطاقه او مشروعات
اعاده الاعمار لاحقا حين يبدا عمليه اعاده
الاعمار مع ملاحظه طبعا ان هذا الم هذه
المصالح ليست جديده لان تركيا كان عندها
مشروعات وعقود مع القذافي بحوالي 15 مليار
دولار وان رغبه منها في تامين هذه
المشروعات والعقود تاخرت في تاييد الثوره
على القذافي عندما اقاله ان الرجل ساقط لا
محاله بدات في تاييد المتظاهرين هناك باء
المصلحه الاوليه التي تشترك فيها
تركيا مع بعيد الدول المختلفه الموجوده
على الساحه اللي بين لكنها تختلف عن
معظم هذه الدول او كل هذه الدول باستثناء
الامارات اللي اعداء مشروع ممثل ولكن في
الاتجاه المعاكس كان عندها انها ادت ايضا
الى ليبيا لدعم مشروعها الكبير وما هو
مشروع الكبير الذي تحدثنا عنه قبل ذلك
وتتعامل فيها او تدعمه فيها تدعم التركيه
في هذا المشروع قطر ايضا هذا المشروع
ببساطه هو
دعم كل تيارات الاسلام السياسى فى ليبيا
وفى كل مكان في العالم في
كل مكان في العالم يعني في الهند والصين
وفي نيجيريا وفي المغرب وفي اوروبا
اردوغان سيست قائمه على دعم التيارات
الاسلام السياسي في كل مكان في العالم طيب
وشكل الدعم هدف وايه ان تصل هذه الاحزاب
الى السلطه اما للسلطه بشكل مطلق راس
السلطه كما وصلت جامعه الاخوان المسلمين
في مصر 12 او ان تكون موجوده في ال
في البرلمان قوى مؤثره او على الاقل قوه
معارضه هذه ال استلام السلطه وحين تصل هذه
الاحزاب الى السلطه تصبح نقطه انطلاق الى
التواصل مع احزاب مماثله وصلت الى السلطه
او في طريقها للوصول في دول اخرى وكل هذه
الدول تصبح عباره عن ولايات تشكل في
مضمونها شو باريس لها طابع اسلامي وسبل
ستاد يعني تعديل جديد او دوله كبرى
المقصود بها يعني
الى الخلافه ليس بالضروره
الخلافه كما كان ايام الدوله العثمانيه
يعني ويكون في الباب العالي وال وال اه
ولكن ان تكون دوله عندها كلها بيسيطر
عليها التيارات الاسلاميه و مركز الثقل
الاساسي هو في اداره كل هذه الدول والنفوذ
عليها هو زعيم العالم الاسلامي السلطان
العثماني او الخليفه العثماني او الرئيس
طيب اردوغان
هل المشروع مشروع جديد يعني ابدا المشروع
القديم وقديم جدا يعني مهم وجود من القرن
التسعطاشر وكان فيه طياريه موجودين في
تركيا مع ضعف الدوله الدوله العثمانيه
واصبحت رجل اوروبا المريض
تفسخها بعد هزيمتها في الحرب العالميه
الاولى كان عندنا طيران تيار قاده الزعيم
مؤسس تركيا الحديثه مصطفى كمال اتترك اللي
شايف انه التركيه تكتفي بحدودها الموجوده
في شبه جزيره البلقان او في اسيا الصغرى
وان وهي تصبح تنازل عن تاريخها مع الدول
الاسلاميه وتصبح دوله اوروبيه حديثه بعيده
من بدات الصلاه مقطوعه الصلب في العالم
الاسلامي وتغيرت الحروف ان تكتب بالحروف
اللاتينيه و كل الكلام اللي حضرتك
الفكره كمال اتاتورك كانت موجوده تاصلت في
النفط
اساتذه الجامعات الصحفيين الكتاب نخبه
المجتمع لكن حلم الخلافه موجود في الارياف
وفي الطبقات العامله وفي الطبقات الاقل
نفوذا في تركيا اعبر عنها
علماء زي مثلا سعيد مرسيليا على ما اذكر
احد اهم وعلماء الاصلاح في تركيا في
العالم الاسلامي وعبر عنه استاذ اه
اردوغان اللي هو نجم الدين اربكان
ابرز
اسلامي في السنوات اللي سبقت ظهور كما
اردوغان وهو الرجل اللي نجح في الوصول
للسلطه في التسعينات ثم سقط نتيجه تكاد
تكاثرا وتكالب ال ما يسمى بالدوله العميقه
الجامعات والجيش الى اخره ف اسقطوا وسقط
موقف لو كان
ان تركيا يجب ان تتواصل مع العالم
الاسلامي وليس مع مكان ترقيع الحقيقي هو
في قلب العالم الاسلامي وليس في اوروبا
وليس هناك من جدوى تحاول تركيا ان تكون
عضوا في الاتحاد الاوروبي لانه قبل وصف
بانه نادي مسيحي من اللي يصفه استاذ
اردوغان اللي هو نجم الدين اربكان اللي
مات في 2011
وارد وغير نفسه
وكان عضو في حزب حزب الرفاه على ما اذكر
داخل السجن في التسعينات لان معبر عن هذه
الافكار اللي بتتكلم عن دور الدين في
الدوله فكره اتحاد دوله الاسلام والامه
الاسلاميه
كان يخالف القوانين العلمانيه اللي موجوده
وقتها ودخل السجن لفتره قبل ان يخفي هذه
الافكار ثم يبدا احنا السعوده الاسلامي
هذه الافكار ببراعه شديده من الفين وواحد
عند تاسيس حزب العداله والتنميه ثم وصل
الى السلطه في 2012 الى 2010 و 2011
الفتره التي اول تسع سنوات نجح فيها اربعه
بهدوء شديد في القضاء واضعاف خصومه اللي
بيسموهم الكماليين نسبه الى مصطفى كمال
اللي عم بيعبروا عن تركيا العلمانيه وليس
تركيا الاسلامي
مع اضعاف هذه
المؤسسات والسيطره على المؤسسه المختلفه
ومنها الجيش والصحافه والاعلام بدا يعبر
رجب طيب اردوغان وحزبه عندنا الاسلامي او
التوالي كان يتكلم عنه استاذ واربع كان
بشكل واضح وكان عنده مشروع كبير جدا هي
فكره سيد طارق الاحزاب الاسلاميه في كل
مكان في العالم وخاطب في ذلك الاداره
الامريكيه
الديمقراطيين واقنعهم كما قلت لكم في حلقه
سابقه انه يجب ان تدعم الاحزاب الاسلاميه
هذا خيركم وخير للعالم الاسلامي ازاي سيد
اردوغان اللغه انه انتو امريكان من الحرب
العالميه الثانيه منذ ان صعد تم الى
السلطه وانتم مكفوفين في الشارع الاسلامي
لان تدعمه الديكتاتوريات هذه الن كدوريات
اما ا
جنرالات عسكريين
[موسيقى]
او انهم يعني دكتاتوريات ملكيه دول الخليج
في الشارع وانظمه
رشاشاتهم بتهدد مصالحك من انه دائما في
حاله العيان في الشارع الاسلامي الافضل ان
تتخلص من هذه الانظمه كلها من المحليه
الخريف في كل العالم الاسلامي مش بس في
العالم العربي وانه ان تسمح بدعم
الديمقراطيه الديمقراطيه ديات لما تكون
صحيحه تاتي بالتيار الاسلامي وان الطيار
الاسلامي ده ليس هناك في افكار ما يخيفكم
ايها الامريكان ليه لانه دول اصدقاء قدامى
تذكرهم بتعاون المسلمين والجماعات
الاسلاميه مع الغرب ومع الامريكان منذ
الخمسينات في مواجهه العدو الكبير اللي هو
الاتحاد السوفياتي والشيوعيه واللهم ان
الاسلام ليس فيه ليس هو اسامه بن لادن
الاسلام ليس هو
الاسلام الملالي والثوره ال اسلاميه في
اسلام معتدل جدا وده نفسه كحزب مثال على
ان وحزبه معتدل متعاون مع الغرب وان هذه
الاحزاب اللي بتمثل ها التي تحكمها افكار
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين يا صديقي للغرب
ولا تخيف ولانها وتقدم ضمان بين الضمان
الاولانيه اللي هم او الخطين الاساسيين
اللي بيخوف الغرب ولا ضمانه لفكره اقتصاد
السوق الحر الاقتصاد المفتوح يعني
الامر الثاني انه لا مساس باسرائيل طيب
الكلام ده
وفيه الفين وعشره يعني علاقه الامريكان
وتوافقهم كانت سرا وفي الفين في اغسطس
الفين وعشره كان فيه قرار اللي هو ال اه
الامن او التوجيه او القرار الجمهوري
الامريكي رقم 11 وده كان بيتكلم على تصور
الامريكان بالتغيير منطقه الشرق الاوسط في
اغسطس الفين وعشره ومازال حتى يعني ال
انضموا على اخر مره 2017 كان من طب مادام
ذكرت انا عرفت منين وغيره انه الناس اللي
شاركوا في اعداد هذا التقرير
تحدثوا مصادر الى نيويورك تايمز
مارك على ما اذكر مراسلي واشنطن بوست في
البيت الابيض ثم اصبح مضمون متداولا في
الجميع يتفق مع ما حدث بعد ثورات الربيع
العربي
لانه يحقق تصور الترقيع الذي وافقت عليه
الامريكان وهذا لا يعني ان انصاركم يعني
عملاء ولا حاجه ولكن بالتوافق وراوا ان في
هذا مصلحه اليوم توافقت كل الاطراف الشارع
والاتراك والامريكان
وهذه القصه قديمه في كل الاحوال هل نجح
هذا المشروع المشروع نجح وزي ما قدر
حضراتكم انه بحلول عام 2012 كان فكره
اردوغان التي باركها الامريكان قد اتت
ثمارها وشفنا احزاب اسلاميه بتحكم المغرب
وفي تونس اللحظه يعني و في ليبيا في
الانتخابات الاوليه عملوا اداء جيد بعد
سقوط القذافي وطبعا وصلوا للسلطه في مصر
الموجودين في فلسطين من خلال حماس
وموجودين قوه كبيره في اليمن وهكذا
بالاضافه انهم قوه مؤثره في الاردن وفي
الكويت الى اخره
القصه كلها انه انهما دعم تركيا دعمت هذه
الاحزاب وكانت صور رجب طيب اردوغان ترفع
في كل مكان في العالم الاسلامي باعتباره
انه الزعيم الاسلامي الاكثر شعبيه مش بس
تعبر عن التغير في التوجه من تركيا دوله
اوروبيه لتخفيض دوله اسلاميه تعبر عنها في
سياسات فعليا تمثلت في دعم معونات لهذه
الاحزاب اه مشروعات اعلان استقبال
لمؤتمرات
زياده كبيره جدا في التجاره ال اه
والمعاملات يعني يكون مثلا مثال واحد انه
في الفين واثنين عندما تولى حزب اردوغان
السلطه كانت حجم التجاره ما بين تركيا وكل
الدول الاسلاميه كانت 8 واربعه من عشره
مليار دولار في 2013 كانت سته تسعه وستين
دولارا وتسعه وستين مليار دولار يعني
اتكلم على تقريبا من اضعاف اضف الى ذلك
بات في تركيا فيها كل المنطق كل المؤتمرات
والمنتديات الاسلاميه زي
منظمه المؤتمر الاسلامي زي مشاركته في
مؤتمر اه جامعه الدول العربيه مجلس
التعاون الخليجي كل الكلام ده تماما
يعني على يعني يسير بنجاح التي 2013
لحضراتكم لانه بدا الدول الاخرى المتضرره
من هذا المشروع تقول تصوره مضاده على هذا
المشروع الذي يهدد هم بالاطاحه بهم ف
تقاضي هذا المشروع الامارات والسعوديه
وبدات في دعمه في مصر وفي مصر بدات نقطه
الثوره ضد هذا المشروع فسقطت حكومه
الاخوان ومن مصر بدات تسقط اه تتراجع
النفوذ الاخوان في سوريا ثم في ليبيا في
المغرب في اليمن الى اخره وطبعا فيه كل
الكلام ده يعني اصبح تاريخ اللي بيحصل في
ليبيا الان انه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان لم
يتنازل عن مشروع الى تعرض لانتكاسه في
ثم ذلك هذه الانتكاسه
يعني باحداث داخليه بدات من اول
او يعني حديقه جيزي المظاهره ضد حزب رقم
شعبيته الجارفه ثم تطورت الاحداث في الى
انقلاب محاوله الانقلاب في يوليو 2016 لكن
كردي انتكاسات قدر يتجاوزها اردوغان ولكنه
لن يتجاوز مشروع ال الكبير اللي دعم على
اساس والربيع العربي طيب
هل هو موجود في بيعمل ايه فى ليبيا
ومحاوله احياء الفكره التي لن يسلم حتى
الان بسقوطها ان نسلم بسقوط الكرديه
الصديق جماعه الاخوان المسلمين عنده على
ارضه عشان كده بدعم اعلامهم علشان كده هو
دعم الحكومه الوفاق وجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين في ليبيا ام انها تعود الى
السلطه وترد نفوس مشيره حافظ مشير خليفه
اللي بالنسبه له بيمثل السياسي في مصر وهو
او العدو الاساسي الى اسقاط حكومه جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين اللي بتمثل القوات او
القوه او الاساس في مشروعه طيب ال القصه
دي اللي موجوده هل هي هو بيعملها في غفله
عن الاخرين هو ما زالت الثوره المضاده او
القوى المضاده للمشروع قائمه وم درهم في
قوى موجوده مفهوم منها كل موجوده يعني مصر
موجوده في ليبيا لان وبينها حدود مشتركه
الف ومائه كيلو وبالتالي
رفض فكره الاخوان او غيره لازم تكون
موجوده على الحدود وكذلك الجزائر لان اي
فوضى على الحدود يعني هي تؤثر عليهم بشكل
مباشر يزيد على كده انا بالنسبه لمصر
وكذلك الجزائر هي بت رفض فكره يعني ال ال
الاسلام السياسي وبالتالي اللي بيقوموا
لفكره انما كمان عندنا ما زال الامارات
والسعوديه موجودين على الاراضي اللي دين
على شيء بالاضافه لمصالحهم وهي كثيره جدا
الاقتصاديه خصوصا الامارات عندها مصالح
اقتصاديه كبيره جدا في ليبيا ممكن نتكلم
عنها في وقت لاحق لكن ايضا ان بتمثل الطرف
الاخر التيار الاخر المقاوم لمشروع الدخان
التيار اللي بيري ان الخطر المحدق عليه
اذا نجح مشروع اردوغان اللي بيقول يجب ان
نزيد كل الانظمه الملكيه والانظمه السابقه
اللي هي انظمه الخليج او زي الانظمه اللي
سقط بفعل مبارك وزين العابدين علي عبد
الله صالح
الوضع ال اه ال ال ال ال في تركيا في في
ليبيا يعني انه الحرب اللي كانت بالوكاله
اصبحت الان اصبحت الان علنا وهي تمثل خطر
وتؤدي الى تصاعد الاحداث
امور كثيره بعد انا ذكرت انه انه الجزائر
لن تقبل خصوصا بعد ان تسترد يعني
استقرارها داخليا لن تقبل بوجود اه دوله
بتقدم اسلحه واسلحه بتزيد يوم بعد يوم
الجامعات موجوده على حدودهم مصر لا يمكن
ان تقبل بوجود هذه الجماعات وبدعم التركي
ليها لانه كل هذه الجماعات جزء منها فر من
مصر او جاء
منها استهداف مصر انتقاما لسقوط جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين والتيار الاسلامي
الامارات لا يمكن وهي زي التركيه تطالب
الجماعات الاسلاميه في كل مكان في العالم
زي ما قلت لحضرتك
السعوديه نفس القصه لكن يزيد عليها امر
واخر انها بطرف المشروع اردوغان خطر اضافي
وهو منافسته على زعامه العالم السني ولا
يحتاج منه حلقه اخرى ان شاء الله اشكركم
[موسيقى]